I never wear head-to-toe white by any
means I don't own any white clothes I
don't own any white sheets usually get
like coffee and myself pretty much every
day I just feel like it's really
dangerous that white things I'm that guy
who has like a stain on the shirt where
is it once and they drop something on it
by the end of the day I'm always covered
in unidentified substances I want to
believe that I'm not gonna be the
messiest but I'm pretty sure I'm gonna
be the messiest it's gonna be hard for
me personally during the work day
because I'm constantly running around
moving stuff this week I'm going to a
theme park so that does not bode well I
have my period just thought the entire
world needed to know that I don't think
I've ever had my period and not ruined
something that's actually gonna be the
thing that makes me lose
[Music]
I'm ready bring all the goods oh [ __ ]
magic I look like I'm going to P Diddy
party I mean this is pretty daunting I
feel like any little speck is gonna get
all over this I'm so fresh and so clean
maybe now I'll be a little bit more
conscious of where my body is maybe this
will make me a better person I'm not
planning on playing dirty but if people
play dirty to me sometimes you got to
play dirty to stay clean just the fact
of life there can be only one winner for
the all-white challenge and it's gonna
be me outside of the Sun all day so I
actually think that we're gonna be
blinding a lot of people now that I'm
wearing white I do not want to take any
frickin chances not a single drip of
anything is getting all these pants
that's not happening
still super clean it's really stressful
and I shouldn't be wearing all weight I
look like a peach no stains I really got
on one coaster and there's an
unidentifiable dark page now I've only
been in the park for like an hour
so I made a mistake of working and
winning
nasty stain on my knee right there first
stain oh so it's day two just moving
this water bottle cart I'm doing great I
thought he was gonna be a challenge but
this might be pretty easy for me clothes
are having the effect on me where I'm
just like hyper conscious of what I'm
doing at all times kind of ruining my
life
same three I'm wearing white
and I am moving I am committed to this
and as I predicted I am getting slightly
dirty when it came to my dog and he he
took a bath and he was scared and so I
was like I need to protect you and I
just didn't even care and so that's how
I got all dirty I definitely was too
cocky going into this and getting my
butt handed to me all right it's morning
of day three and my clothes are still
super clean good strange
I just ate this wonderful pizza and now
I've got this wonderful stain right here
I'm losing as you can tell I'm so ready
to get out of these white clothes but
fact that I have to slowly eat and
really pay attention everything I'm
doing is driving me nuts so I'm wearing
this jacket cuz I was a little cold but
Solorio enrolled
rappings and around her waist there's a
stain on my booty okay I'm not the one
who I am getting dirtier by the second
it just looks so dirty I schemed to
myself and sabotage myself because I put
on self-tanning lotion and it's seeping
through but I will not lose so next I'll
be wearing this white paint suit to
sabotage the rest of them and keep
myself clean for the rest of the day
cheaters win so I just seen Chantelle
walk in I'm gonna go for it I'm gonna
just do it and run there we go Oh
no did it it mind if I'll get to I'm at
it
yeah so Salaam has no idea that was me
who found out her location so you send a
slicer run
I'm on the shoot of my video right now
Carl just ran in put frickin marker on
my pants This Means War
oh wow really got you good oh yeah I get
them we should get him Carl is around
the corner and I have this marker that's
of coffee we're all going over to the
same place right now we're gonna find a
spot we're gonna plant ourselves we're
messy people and we went a week wearing
white clothing talk about the elephant
in the room which is Carl I'm sorry I
caved and I went dark I think what set
me off was I tried to do a self-tan and
then it started to seep through I
panicked I was like oh no I'm gonna lose
and I just went crazy the world is very
dirty and if you're wearing colored
clothes you don't really see it I feel
like I'm gonna start washing my clothes
more frequently not wearing black pants
I was just very hyper aware of
everything that was happening I was like
okay we're holding eyeliner up here the
second I did get dirty though I was like
relieved I don't know what happened this
was probably my cleanest week ever I was
very focused on my movements which made
it very difficult to focus on anything
else that was very stressful I guess
like in any situation you have nice
things that you have to show up you just
have to
extra precautions having the stakes
raised made me try harder I know that I
lost but I think a clear winner is hard
to choose I was between Brandon and Carl
but since Carl sabotage I guess Brandon
is the winner I feel like all of us win
except for Carl
are we not rhyming we're just
[Music]